in the lobby of Ramsey solutions will
and Kara are with us hey guys how are
you
oh thank you good to have you guys where
are you from
we're from Knoxville Tennessee oh really
well so am i from that area I was born
in Maryville as a matter of fact just
south of theirs what part of Knoxville
we live on the east side over by the zoo
oh yeah all right cool good for you
so you're all the way over here to
Nashville to do your debt-free scream
yes sir how much have you paid off paid
off $80,000 good for you and how long
did that take took us nine years and
nine months nine years and nine months
making what kind of money we started out
taking making about fifteen thousand and
now our incomes about sixty five
thousand good for you excellent now is
eighty thousand house and everything no
nope okay and so how much is what was
the eighty thousand what kind of debt
was that Leslie student loans about
fifty five student loans ten on a car
and the remainder is medical cool what
do you all do for a living now she stays
home yeah I'm a homeschooling mom we
have five children
okay I work as a software engineer oh
very good okay well that's a long
journey nine years sure is
so now have you been doing our stuff
nine years or tell me the story what
happened here well about ten years ago a
member with whom we go to church he
encouraged us to go to a live event and
and I was of course skeptical because
I'm you know just money stuff is kind of
dry and whatnot but we went and you know
halfway through the day we during the
break we were already talking about how
we could make it work and how how we
that we decided we needed to do it and
we're talking about the logistics of how
it would work and and then a couple
weeks later I found out I was pregnant
with our first child I loved it so I
quit my job and will here decided that
he would drop out of a ph.d program and
so he got out with his master's and
slowly over you
and years gradually worked his way into
IT okay very cool very cool I'm trying
to remember 10 years ago where that
event was you remember where it was it
was at until Holly Hills oh yeah right
out there by you guys there right where
you live man that's what that is a long
time ago nice people in that church too
good folks okay very cool very cool so
eighty thousand dollars yeah ChIP chip
chip an away for nine years and nine
yeah and all the way from a fifteen
thousand dollar income up to an up to a
$65,000 in so what what how do you this
isn't that the length of time you fought
through this is very impressive
meanwhile having five kids and that
that's impressive
so you know I'm trying to think if I'm
listening in my car out there riding
around I'm going Wow how did you keep on
how many times did you fall off the
wagon and have to get back on or how did
you stay inspired at any level for that
period of time you know it was a very
long time and it was very difficult and
we never majorly fell off the wagon
because even before the Total Money
Makeover we were not living we've never
been materialistic so when we started we
didn't have anything to sell so we we
lived like no one else for 10 almost ten
years we just how do we keep it up well
we knew that there was no choice but to
become free of it
so become free of the debt and so what
else do you but do but keep on pressing
forward
there's nowhere but up a man that's it
very cool well what was the hardest part
for you on this yeah yeah my wife we
talked about this question I would say
just saying no you know I don't have a
pension for buying expensive things but
you know we like to eat out or we're
social people and at times telling
people we couldn't eat out with them we
can't go out after church or sure we
can't I can't go out with the guys at
work
and eating I'm bringing my lights of for
10 years for noodles and trying to eat
healthy cuz a lot of inexpensive is not
very healthy yeah it's been living like
no one else and driving beaters
literally eating beans and rice and
frozen veggies yes now that you're there
how does it feel well we just got into a
serious accident about two weeks ago so
our vehicle was totaled
now it has not been earth-shattering
because you should have had insurance
sighs oh yes the other individual did
not but yes we did have insurance and we
had savings was a deductible yeah so
well there was no deductible because it
was uninsured oh yeah okay but it was
not earth shattering because we did have
savings and we weren't in debt and we
didn't have all these payments flying
out of the house and so some of the
drama out of drama it does it's just
that you know we went from just getting
out of debt to this next major financial
earthquake and we just had to you know
like well this is where everyone is
going now you know what I mean like we
have to buy a vehicle we know there's
gonna be a little hiccup and before we
start something like our three to six
months yeah yeah okay well you're you
got a plan and there's no doubt about it
you guys can carry a plan out
congratulations you're impressive thank
you very impressive people Wow very neat
all right here we go will and Cara Liam
James
Ian John and Eamonn Eamonn thank you for
that are we gonna gather up the home
yeah all right let's get them all in
here all boys yes all five boys look at
you mom homeschooling those got you a
basketball team yeah all right $80,000
paid off in nine years and nine months
making 15 to making 65,000 a year
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
somebody's been practicing well done
that was awesome you guys very fun very
fun hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim